okay so let's just finish up with
sharpie gate with what is sort of the
obvious revelation it's now being
reported that Donald Trump personally
used the Sharpie to draw a bubble on
Hurricane Dorian's track map which was
inaccurate we don't want to give more
importance to sharpie gate than it
deserves especially when when you look
at what Donald Trump is doing at the
border geopolitically with Iran with
climate with our allies that is also
much worse and so much more impactful
than sharpie gate but Sharpie gate is
worth talking about in that it reflects
a delusional and unsettling commitment
to an absolutely backwards version of
the truth that signals a fundamentally
unwell person and Donald Trump which
won't come as a surprise to people who
have been watching me for a while so to
catch you up if you haven't followed
this story and I envy you if that's the
case Donald Trump tweeted last week that
hurricane durian was putting Alabama at
risk
it wasn't instead of just saying oh it
wasn't Donald Trump doubled tripled and
quadrupled down climaxing in holding up
a version of the hurricane track map
that had an additional bubble drawn
around parts of Alabama now this was not
an official weather map and we knew it
was doctored partially because as more
as you go into the future the whole way
let me see if I can explain this the way
that these cones of possible hurricane
trajectory work is that they become
wider and more encompassing over time
because uncertainty goes up the further
into the future you're predicting so the
fact that a smaller cone of the possible
track was was drawn in later in the
hurricane is mathematically impossible
but putting if you didn't realize that
this was not an official weather map we
knew it was doctored but the White House
now is saying that Donald Trump
personally drew the Sharpie bubble this
is according to the Washington Post an
official from the White House saying
that quote no one else writes like that
on a map with a black sharpie now I will
tell you this is so obvious to me the
only thing that makes me doubted is that
when I imagine Donald Trump drawing I
don't envision him having a steady
enough hand to draw such a clean circle
between his sort of erratic demeanor in
speeches his sniffing and huffing and
puffing his signature that looks like an
EKG I would imagine if you told Donald
Trump to draw a circle that it would be
a shaky circle but other than that of
course we suspected that Donald Trump
did this himself
this makes his confused denial the other
day even funnier though remember this
when Donald Trump was asked about a
Sharpie being used and he just looked
away and repeated that he doesn't know
it was him of course it was him the
whole time and another minor flub again
that no one would have cared about had
Donald Trump not tripled down and
quadrupled down on it it's sort of like
the supposedly record-setting
inauguration crowd all over again or
three to five million people voted
illegally for Hillary Clinton and
otherwise I would have won the popular
vote you say it once as outrageous as it
is but then you just let it go or admit
that you were wrong or at least you
don't fight it tooth and nail and it
mostly goes away instead when you go
after it and double and triple and
quadruple down it becomes huge and
hugely embarrassing to anyone who even
has the capability to have a sense of
shame it's not clear Donald Trump does
and this is just insecurity right when
you are so insecure that you can't even
admit to the most minor mistake you
really show what is actually going on
there and this is not you know mind
reading or speculation it's the most
benign possible explanation of Donald
Trump choosing to double triple and
quadruple down on obvious lies
insecurity is the least bad explanation
the others are far far worse so maybe
this is the end of sharpie gate I don't
know but we will see if this rears its
ugly head again